Hong Kong only has one proper election
and it's every four years it's for local
councils and this is it it's not usually
considered very important but in truth
there has never been an election here
quite like this one from the early
morning they lined up to vote in record
numbers more people have registered to
vote than ever before more candidates
are standing and every seat is being
contested for the very first time the
young may have characterized the six
months of protests here but all ages
turned out determined to cast their vote
the council's may rule on parks and
recycling but this is about much more
than that it's a message ROM is not
about in a day
tiny drops of water make the mighty
ocean so you see you see this is very
much the start of a sort of it that
everyone has to sacrifice a bit put in
some effort
let's change this very importantly we
need to show our our thoughts to the
government because it is the only one
way is peaceful
we have many protects for government
oculist evening we are broken the law or
something but this is the only one thing
we can bring our family to show them
there's been so much bitterness and
violence between pro-beijing and
pro-democracy groups that it seemed
inconceivable they could appear together
but here they were peacefully hunting
for voters side by side blue for the
Democracy party and red for pro-beijing
North Point is the pro-beijing heartland
but even their candidate admits he's
worried if you only talk about the
district at the surface in the district
I think I can get advantage among the
free candidate but if you talk about the
social a smokier
i think i is it's not in my control so
really difficult to predict the results
the Hong Kong government is hoping that
across the city people will vote against
the disruption caused by the process but
the protest organizers are convinced
they have the support of the people and
are demanding that the government
listens hey mom Andy I'll put you wish
you go home I'm taking a hydration that
seems on money why do you think I say
we're gone what you've got or you can
see that even a landslide to the
pro-democracy parties will have little
immediate effect on politics here but it
would send a message to the government
that six months on the protest movement
remains strong and crucially it's
supported by the people this is arguably
the most important local council
election ever stuarti Sky News Hong Kong